You know, your eyes go through a lot. Every day with things like reading and dim light, too much screen time, that happens to me all the time. Bright sun in your eyes when you're driving. Even nighttime driving can cause eye strain. So, yeah, we're putting our eyes through a lot. So it's important to take care of them and monitor their health with regular eye exams. Check their healthy with an eye exam at spec savers from $99, which includes an OCT eye health scan that helps to detect eye. and health conditions at early stages.
你知道，你的眼睛承受了很多。每天看书、处在昏暗的光线中、盯着屏幕太久，我经常这样。开车时刺眼的阳光直射眼睛。甚至夜间开车也会导致视疲劳。所以，是的，我们的眼睛承受了很大的负荷。因此，定期进行眼科检查来照顾它们并监测它们的健康状况非常重要。在 Specsavers 进行 99 美元起的眼科检查来确认眼睛健康，其中包括 OCT 眼部健康扫描，有助于在早期阶段检测出眼部疾病和健康状况。
To find a location near you and book an eye exam with an OCT scan from $99, visit specksavers. I exams are provided by independent optometrists. Prices may vary by location. Hi, everyone. It is Thanksgiving, and we are taking the week off, but we wanted to highlight an original Odyssey podcast, and we're going to feature it today. Yes, it is called Gone South, and it is an award-winning true crime documentary podcast. Season four is out now, and it tells a different story about one of the South's most interesting crimes.
要查找附近的门店并预约 99 美元起的包含 OCT 扫描的眼科检查，请访问 specsavers。眼科检查由独立的验光师提供。价格可能因门店而异。大家好。今天是感恩节，我们要休假一周，但我们想重点推荐一个原版的 Odyssey 播客，我们今天将对其进行专题介绍。是的，它叫《绝境南方》（Gone South），这是一个屡获殊荣的真实犯罪纪录片播客。第四季现已推出，它讲述了一个关于南方最有趣罪行之一的不同故事。
You can tune in every week as writer and host Jed Lipinski takes you through one of these crimes. You will hear from the person who committed the crime, the person who solved it, are both. Gone South not only sheds fascinating insights into the criminal mind, but also into human nature. Enjoy this preview. If you ever have a chance to visit the Louisiana State Penitentiary, and I hope you don't, you'll notice something unusual on the way in. Right outside the front entrance, there's a gift shop, a prison gift shop. They sell various trinkets and posters, and you could even walk away with a t-shirt,
你可以每周收听，作家兼主持人杰德·利平斯基（Jed Lipinski）将带你了解其中一桩罪行。你将听到犯下罪行的人、破案的人，或者两者兼有。《绝境南方》不仅对犯罪心理有着迷人的见解，对人性也有深刻的洞察。请欣赏这段预告片。如果你有机会参观路易斯安那州立监狱，我希望你没有机会，你会注意到入口处有些不寻常的地方。就在正门外面，有一个礼品店，一个监狱礼品店。他们出售各种小饰品和海报，你甚至可以带走一件 T 恤，
a t-shirt with a picture of the prison entrance, and a caption underneath that reads, A Gated Community. Louisiana State Penitentiary sits on 18,000. acres just south of the Mississippi border. The prison is better known as Angola, because the land it occupies used to be a slave plantation, and a majority of the people enslaved there were taken from the West African country of Angola. The plantation became a prison in 1880, but an outside observer would have noticed almost no change. Inmates lived in former slave quarters. They worked the fields just as slaves had. They lived short and brutal lives. Conditions hardly improved
一件印有监狱入口图片的 T 恤，下面配有一行字：一个封闭式社区。路易斯安那州立监狱坐落在密西西比州边界以南占地 18,000 英亩的土地上。这座监狱更为人所知的名字是安哥拉（Angola），因为这片土地曾经是一个奴隶种植园，那里被奴役的大多数人都是从西非国家安哥拉被抓来的。该种植园于 1880 年变成了一座监狱，但外面的观察者会发现几乎没有任何改变。囚犯们住在过去的奴隶宿舍里。他们像奴隶一样在田地里劳作。他们过着短暂而残酷的生活。条件几乎没有改善
in the 20th century. After a plague of murders, stabbings, and sexual assaults got the attention of the press in the 1960s, Angola was named the bloodiest prison in America. And it was almost impossible to escape. Angola is surrounded on three sides by the Mississippi River. It's hemmed in on the other by dense, snake-infested swamp land. Guards patrol the grounds on horseback, armed with 12-gauge shotguns. Its layout is devilishly complex. It's headishly complex. multiple outbuildings, barriers, and sniper towers are designed to prevent escapes. Even if an inmate did escape, they often drowned in the Mississippi's rushing currents, or succumbed to exposure, or got bitten by a rattlesnake.
在 20 世纪。在 20 世纪 60 年代的一连串谋杀、刺伤和性侵事件引起媒体的关注后，安哥拉被冠以美国最血腥监狱的称号。而且几乎不可能逃脱。安哥拉的三面都被密西西比河环绕。另一面则被密密麻麻、毒蛇盘踞的沼泽地包围。警卫骑着马在场地上巡逻，手持 12 号猎枪。它的布局极其复杂。它的布局极其复杂。多栋附属建筑、路障和狙击手塔楼旨在防止逃跑。即使囚犯真的逃跑了，他们也经常在密西西比河湍急的水流中溺水身亡，或者因暴露在恶劣环境中而死，或者被响尾蛇咬伤。
And according to those who tried, a failed escape could be a fate worse than death. The punishment for escaping included months, if not years, in solitary, or what inmates called the dungeon. one visitor in the 1970s described as medieval. And yet in the 1980s, one inmate successfully escaped from Angola not once, but twice. I don't know if you can even fathom it, but it's a big thrill when you successfully escape incarceration. It's undescribable, man. Better feeling than any narcotic I ever had.
根据那些尝试过的人所说，逃跑失败的下场可能比死还要糟糕。逃跑的惩罚包括数月甚至数年的禁闭，或者囚犯们所说的地牢。2020 年代的一位访客将其形容为中世纪的刑罚。然而，在 20 世纪 80 年代，一名囚犯成功从安哥拉逃脱，不是一次，而是两次。我不知道你是否能想象得到，但当你成功逃脱监禁时，那是一种巨大的刺激。那种感觉无法用言语形容，老兄。比我体验过的任何麻醉剂感觉都要好。
I'm Jed Lipinski. From Odyssey Podcasts, this is Gone South. In this episode, I'm going to tell you the story of Jimmy Cox. You won't find any books, podcasts, or movies about Jimmy. His story has never been told, at least not in that way. I met Jimmy during the making of Gone South Season 2 about the Dixie Mafia, a loose-knit group of criminals who roamed the South in the 60s and 70s. If you listen to that season, you probably remember a guy named Kirksey Knicks Jr.
我是杰德·利平斯基。来自 Odyssey 播客，这里是《绝境南方》。在本集节目中，我将为你讲述吉米·科克斯（Jimmy Cox）的故事。你找不到任何关于吉米的图书、播客或电影。他的故事从未被讲述过，至少没有以这种方式讲述过。我在制作《绝境南方》第二季时遇到了吉米，那一季讲的是迪克西黑手党（Dixie Mafia），这是一群在 60 年代和 70 年代游荡于南方的松散犯罪集团。如果你听过那一季，你可能还记得一个叫柯西·尼克斯二世（Kirksey Knicks Jr.）的人。
Unlike Jimmy, Kirksey is an infamous criminal. Some people believe he was the leader of the Dixie Mafia, though Kirksey disputes that. He's been locked up for over 50 years. When we were making that season, I had trouble getting in touch with Kirksey. For months, my letters to him went unanswered. Then I got an email from a guy named Jimmy Cox. Jimmy said he was a close friend of Kirksey's, dating back to the mid-70s when they'd served time at Angola together.
与吉米不同，柯西是一个声名狼藉的罪犯。有些人认为他是迪克西黑手党的头目，尽管柯西对此有异议。他已经被关押了 50 多年。我们在制作那一季的时候，很难联系到柯西。几个月来，我写给他的信都石沉大海。然后我收到一个叫吉米·科克斯的人发来的电子邮件。吉米说他是柯西的密友，两人的交情可以追溯到 20 世纪 70 年代中期，当时他们一起在安哥拉服刑。
He told me Kirksey would be willing to speak with me if I spoke with Jimmy first. A week later, I was talking with Kirksey Nix. Jimmy made only a small appearance in season two of our show, but I thought his person story was worth telling. I used to be a crime reporter for the Times-Picayune in New Orleans, and I'd been to Angola before. It was hard to imagine how someone could escape that place and live to tell the tale. We'll get there, don't worry. But first, I want to tell you a little bit more about the escape artist. Jimmy Cox grew up on the north side of Chicago in the 50s and 60s, the second youngest of 12 kids. His father had ties to the Chicago Mafia. So did some
他告诉我，如果我先和吉米谈谈，柯西会愿意跟我谈谈。一周后，我就在和柯西·尼克斯交谈了。吉米在我们节目的第二季中只露面了一小会儿，但我认为他的个人故事值得讲述。我曾是新奥尔良《时代花絮报》（Times-Picayune）的一名犯罪记者，我以前去过安哥拉。很难想象怎么有人能逃离那个地方并活下来讲出这个故事。我们会讲到那里的，别担心。但首先，我想向你多介绍一下这位逃狱大师。吉米·科克斯在 50 年代和 60 年代长大于芝加哥北区，是 12 个孩子中倒数第二小的。他的父亲与芝加哥黑手党有联系。他的一些
of his older brothers. He started hustling at a young age. When we were little kids, I can remember we used to break into the freight trains. And one time we broke in one was full of beer. We had beer stashed all over the neighborhood, different places. And we didn't drink all of it, you know, but it was just fun to do it. We stole a half a train car full of beer. And we're little kids. I'm talking about nine, ten years old probably.
哥哥也有联系。他很小就开始混社会了。当我们还是小孩子的时候，我记得我们经常闯入货运列车。有一次我们闯进了一列满载啤酒的列车。我们在社区的各处藏了啤酒，在不同的地方。我们并没有把它们全喝完，你知道的，但这样做很有趣。我们偷了半车厢的啤酒。我们当时还是小孩子。我大概说的是九岁、十岁左右。
That was our mentality. And you've got to figure, I come from the area where you see gang. Gangsters walking around, you know, nice clothes, diamond rings, driving nice cars, having nice women. So that's what you aspire to. When he wasn't robbing freight trains, young Jimmy shined shoes at a local social club where his father's friends hung out. A bunch of old Italian guys hung out in there and everything. Well, I was allowed to go in and shine the shoes for him. That was my turf.
那是我们的心态。你得想一想，我来自这样一个地方：你看到帮派分子到处走动，穿着得体的衣服，戴着钻戒，开着漂亮的汽车，身边有漂亮的女人。所以这就是你所向往的。当年轻的吉米不抢劫货运列车时，他会在他父亲的朋友们闲逛的当地社交俱乐部擦鞋。一群老意大利家伙在那里闲逛什么的。嗯，我被允许进去为他们擦鞋。那是我的地盘。
One of the gangsters who hung out at the club was a guy named Big Polly. Well, Big Polly was the boss, and he'd sit in his barber's chair, and I'd shine his shoes, and when I'd get through, he'd reach in his pocket and pull out his big old roll of money, and whatever Bill was on the top, he would hold it over his shoe, and if he could see his reflection, he'd give it to me. So I was shined a shit out of those shoes. One day I was down there shining, I'm going to do it, reach it over my shoulder, shot Pauley four or five times in the head.
在俱乐部闲逛的黑帮分子中有一个叫“大波利”（Big Polly）的人。嗯，大波利是老大，他会坐在理发椅上，我给他擦鞋，等我擦完后，他会把手伸进口袋，掏出他那一大叠厚厚的钱，无论哪张钞票在最上面，他都会把它举到鞋子上方，如果他能看到自己的倒影，他就会把它给我。所以我把那些鞋擦得锃亮。有一天我在那里擦鞋，我要这么做，把手伸过我肩膀，朝波利的头部开枪四五次。
the old men hustled me out of there and told me, don't tell nobody nothing, just go home. I remember I used to keep my shoeshine box in the basement, and they had a big wash tub down there, and I went down there and I washed the blood out of my head. I mean, there was stuff everywhere. It traumatized me. I ain't too proud to say that. Jimmy says he never told anyone, including his dad, about what he'd seen. He figured the guy who shot Polly must have known him well enough to walk
老头子们把我哄了出去，告诉我，什么也别对任何人说，直接回家。我记得我以前把擦鞋箱放在地下室里，那里有一个大洗衣盆，我走到那儿，把头上的血洗掉。我的意思是，到处都是血。这对我造成了精神创伤。我不羞于承认这一点。吉米说他从来没有对任何人，包括他父亲，提起过他所看到的事情。他琢磨着开枪打波利的那个人一定很了解他，才能毫不受阻地
straight into the shop unacosted. So therefore I felt that I should never trust a soul. And it was the catalyst to put me on. If I felt that you were a threat, I was going to eliminate you first because I wasn't going to let you eliminate me. Jimmy dropped out of school in sixth grade. He says he learned to drive by stealing cars. By his early teens, he developed a reputation as a solid getaway driver.
直接走进店里。因此我觉得我永远不应该信任任何人。这就是催化剂，把我推上了这条路。如果我觉得你是一个威胁，我会先消灭你，因为我不会让你消灭我。吉米在六年级时辍学了。他说他是通过偷车学会开车的。刚到十几岁时，他就以一个稳健的甩尾车手而闻名。
These guys were going to do a bank job. They wanted three stolen cars, and they wanted me to place them in certain spots for them, right? Switch cars, they call it. And I told them, I'll do the driving. I was like 14 years old and made $17,500. It was a lot of money back then. A whole lot of money. It was a whole lot of money.
这些家伙要去干一笔银行买卖。他们想要三辆偷来的车，他们希望我把它们安置在特定的地点，对吧？他们称之为换车。我告诉他们，我来开车。我当时大约 14 岁，赚了 17,500 美元。在当时这是一大笔钱。一大笔钱。那真是一大笔钱。
About $170,000 today. In the late 60s, when Jimmy was in his early 20s, he moved to Hollywood, where his father ran protection rackets for the local mob. You know, Chicago people run L.A. Jimmy and his friends did errands and odd jobs for him and his associates. One day my dad told me, said, I want you to take your crew and go bust this Chinese restaurant up at right at lunchtime when it's most busy. He said, just pull up front, go on with some baseball bats. Don't hurt nobody if you don't have to. He said, but break shit up.
相当于今天的 170,000 美元左右。60 年代末，吉米 20 出头时，他搬到了好莱坞，他的父亲在那里为当地黑帮经营保护伞。你知道的，芝加哥人在洛杉矶掌权。吉米和他的朋友们为他和他的同伙跑腿、做杂务。有一天我父亲告诉我，他说，我想要你带上你的人去把这家中餐厅砸了，就在午餐时间最忙的时候。他说，把车停在正门前，带上棒球棒进去。如果不是非不得已，不要伤害任何人。他说，但要把东西砸个稀巴烂。
Because a dude wouldn't want to pay his street tax. So we jacked a limousine, pull a limousine. right up in front of it, about four of us bailed out of it with baseball bats, went inside, started breaking up tables and generally causing chaos and scaring the heck out of people. And the guy got his mind right and started paying his taxes. Before long, Jimmy was an established player in L.A. He bought a small nightclub near the corner of LeBrella and Sunset and named it the Wee, spelled OUI, after the adult magazine of the same name.
因为这家伙不肯交街道税。所以我们劫了一辆豪华轿车，把豪华轿车直接停在店门前，我们大约四个人从车里跳出来，拿着棒球棒，走进里面开始砸桌子，大肆制造混乱，把人们吓得半死。那家伙脑子清醒了过来，开始交税了。没过多久，吉米就成了洛杉矶的一个老练玩家。他在勒布雷拉（LeBrella）和日落大道的交角附近买下了一家小型夜总会，并把它命名为“Wee”，拼写为 OUI，取自同名成人杂志。
It was a place where hustlers could come in there at the end of the evening. I had the cops paid off. You could buy cocaine right there at the table, a little glass vial for 100 bucks, and they'd bring it to it right with your drinks, you know? And it was a place for hustlers and thugs and gangsters to hang out and be comfortable. In L.A., Jimmy developed an addiction to heroin and PCP, and he had plenty of run-ins with the law. He was arrested for armed robbery, assault, and car theft, among other things.
这是一个让江湖中人能在傍晚结束时进来聚聚的地方。我已经买通了警察。你甚至可以在桌子旁买到可卡因，一小瓶玻璃罐只要 100 美元，他们会和你的饮料一起直接送到你面前，你知道吗？这是一个供江湖骗子、暴徒和黑帮闲逛并感到自在的地方。在洛杉矶，吉米对海洛因和 PCP（苯环利定）产生了瘾，并且他经常与法律发生冲突。他因武装抢劫、袭击和偷车等罪名被捕。
Yeah, it's hard to remember, but, you know, because I'd go to jail sometimes three times in one week. But Jimmy always avoided significant jail time until 1975, when he was sent to New Orleans to do a job. Jimmy told me what happened next. It's a harrowing story, but he didn't want to go into it on the record. Suffice it to say, the cops tracked him down in L.A. a year later and charged him with Rob, and two counts of first-degree murder. Jimmy's days as a flashy L.A. gangster were over. He was given two life sentences without the possibility of parole.
是的，很难记住，但是，你知道的，因为我有时一周进三次监狱。但吉米总是能逃过重刑，直到 1975 年他被派往新奥尔良执行任务。吉米告诉我接下来发生了什么。这是一个凄惨的故事，但他不想在公开记录中详述。简而言之，警察一年后在洛杉矶追踪到了他，并指控他犯有抢劫罪和两项一级谋杀罪。吉米作为浮华的洛杉矶黑帮的日子结束了。他被判处两次终身监禁且不得假释。
And since Jimmy's crimes were committed in New Orleans, those life sentences would be served at the Louisiana State Penitentiary. This show is sponsored by BetterHelp. You know, just because it's a new year, that does not mean you have to be a new you. But maybe you want to be a less burdened you, a clearer you. Not a totally new you,
由于吉米的罪行是在新奥尔良犯下的，这些无期徒刑将在路易斯安那州立监狱服刑。本节目由 BetterHelp 赞助播出。你知道，新年新气象并不意味着你必须脱胎换骨变成一个全新的人。但也许你想卸下一些负担，让头脑更清醒。不是要变成一个完全不同的人，
but maybe like you just want to hone in. You want to refine. Yeah. I like that. Refine. Well, therapy can help more easily identify what is weighing you down, what might be holding you back.
而可能只是想专注于内心。你想要精益求精。是的。我喜欢这个词。精益求精。嗯，心理治疗可以帮助你更轻松地识别是什么在让你感到沉重，是什么可能在拖你的后腿。
You can better understand your relationships, your motivations, your emotions. I'm trying to let go of just sort of stressing about the small things. Mm-hmm. Because those really just add up. Mm-hmm. And they're going to be just fine.
你可以更好地理解你的人际关系、你的动机、你的情绪。我正试图不再为那些琐事感到压力。嗯哼。因为那些小事真的会积少成多。嗯哼。而且一切都会好起来的。
Well, and you might need help identifying what are small things, what are big things. BetterHelp therapists can help. With over 30,000 therapists, BetterHelp is the world's largest online therapy platform, having served over 5 million people globally. BetterHelp makes it easy to get matched online with a qualified therapist. Sign up and get 10% off at BetterHelp.com slash office ladies. That's Better, H-E-L-P.com slash office ladies. When Jimmy arrived in Angola in 1976, it had only recently been dubbed the bloodiest prison in America. He remembers his first day inside. When I got there and I'm walking to Chow, I noticed a kind of a little traffic jam down there because it's a long, long walk way you have to walk.
嗯，你可能需要帮助来辨别什么是小事，什么是大事。BetterHelp 的治疗师可以提供帮助。BetterHelp 拥有超过 30,000 名治疗师，是全球最大的在线心理治疗平台，已为全球超过 500 万人服务。BetterHelp 让你可以轻松地在网上匹配到合格的治疗师。注册并在 BetterHelp.com/officeladies 上享受九折优惠。网址是 Better, H-E-L-P.com/officeladies。当吉米于 1976 年到达安哥拉时，这里不久前才被冠以美国最血腥监狱的称号。他回忆起自己进去的第一天。当我到达那里并走向食堂时，我注意到那里有点交通堵塞，因为那是一条很长很长的步行道。
You have to walk maybe almost a quarter of a mile to the Chauhaw. When I got up to where the traffic jam was happening, I noticed a dude was laying on the walk. all stabbed up and people were just stepping over him. Wouldn't impan him, no mind, wasn't seeing if he needed. You know, they helped if he was dead or what. So that set the stage for me right there. And what did you think when you saw that? What I thought, I'm in the jungle.
你可能得走将近四分之一英里才能到食堂。当我走到交通堵塞的地方时，我注意到一个人躺在人行道上，身上到处都是刀伤，人们只是从他身上跨过去。根本不理睬他，也不看看他是否需要。你知道的，他们也不管他是死是活。所以那就在当时当地为我奠定了基调。当你看到那一幕时，你在想什么？我当时想，我在丛林里。
Oddly enough, it was probably the safest time to be an Angola inmate in the prison's 100-year history. Between 1969 and 1974, 53 prisoners were murdered by other inmates. The federal government responded by instituting a series of reforms, but Jimmy wasn't impressed. And besides, he had only one goal in mind when he arrived. Your plan was always to escape, right? Oh, yeah. No human being is supposed to be confined. I don't even put my dogs in cages.
说也奇怪，这可能是安哥拉监狱 100 年历史上囚犯最安全的一段时期。在 1969 年到 1974 年间，有 53 名囚犯被其他囚犯谋杀。联邦政府通过实施一系列改革作出了回应，但吉米并不买账。况且，他刚到时脑子里只有一个目标。你的计划一直是越狱，对吧？哦，是的。没有任何人类应该被禁锢。我连我的狗都不关在笼子里。
My main focus was on trying to get away, but we're sitting on an 18,000-acre farm surrounded by the Mississippi on one side and the Tunica Hills and Panthers. and bears and rattlesnakes on the other side. So I knew I had to do something with a little more finesse to it than just trying to run through the bushes. Jimmy knew the stories of other men who tried to escape. In 1975, the year before Jimmy showed up, four men escaped after taking a prison guard hostage
我的主要精力都集中在设法逃跑上，但我们身处一个占地 18,000 英亩的农场，一面被密西西比河包围，另一面则是图尼卡山丘（Tunica Hills）、美洲狮、熊和响尾蛇。所以我知道我必须采取一些比单纯试图在灌木丛中奔跑更有技巧的手段。吉米知道其他尝试越狱的人的故事。1975 年，即吉米出现的前一年，有四名囚犯在劫持了一名监狱看守并用走私的 .22 口径手枪射杀另一名看守后逃跑了。但监狱追捕队的寻血猎犬很快追上了他们。其中两名囚犯投降并被命令趴在地上。据其中一名幸存者称，一名看守用冲锋枪处决了他们两人。该看守从未被指控犯罪。吉米在安哥拉的前四年都在讨论不同的越狱策略。然后他找到了一个他中意的。有一天我在操场上，我走到这几个聊天的朋友跟前，
and shooting another with a smuggled 22-caliber pistol. But bloodhounds for the prison's chase team quickly overtook them. Two of the men surrendered and were told to lay on the ground. According to one of the survivors, a guard executed them both with a submachine gun. The guard was never charged with a crime. Jimmy spent his first four years at Angola debating different escape strategies. Then he found one he liked. One day I was on the yard and I walked up on these friends of mine talking,
他们正在谈论一个刚从新奥尔良慈善医院（Charity Hospital）逃出来的人。我问他，我说，那他妈是怎么做到的？他们说，嗯，他们甚至不用上吊。他们只是把你用镣铐铐在床上然后就离开，吉米。我说，好吧，见鬼，我这就离开。你是怎么做到的？他们说，嗯，他割伤了自己的眼睛。所以我去了，我试着割伤自己的眼睛。
and they were talking about this guy that had just escaped from charity hospital in New Orleans. And I asked him, I said, well, how the hell he'd do that? and they said, well, they don't even hang. They just shackle you to the bed and leave, Jimmy. I said, well, hell, I'm out of here. How do you get there? They said, well, he cut his eye. So I went and I tried to cut my eye.
我甚至花钱雇人这么做。但没有用。所以我回来了，做了更多的研究，我翻阅了《格氏解剖学》（Gray's Anatomy）来寻找我可以下手的地方，但我把它弄砸了。我有这些麻痹眼睛的小眼药水，让一个家伙把针扎进去。
I even paid a guy to do it. And it didn't work. So I came back, did a little more research, and I got into the Graze Anatomy to see where I could mess with it, but I'm messing it up. And I've got these little medical drops that numb your eye, had a dude stick a needle in it.
吉米计划的第一部分成功了。他被送往新奥尔良的慈善医院接受治疗。他走私了一把自制小刀，还有一把用来打开值班警卫使用的手铐的钥匙。但当他试图打开手铐时，钥匙不管用了。所以吉米当场急中生智。他要求值班警卫放松手铐，声称手铐切断了他的血液循环。
The first part of Jimmy's plan worked. He was sent to Charity Hospital in New Orleans for treatment. He smuggled in a makeshift knife, plus a key to open the handcuffs the guards on duty used. But when he tried to open the cuffs, the key didn't work. So Jimmy improvised. He asked the guard on duty to loosen the handcuffs, claiming they were cutting off his circulation.
然后当警卫离开时，他从手铐里滑了出来。他从洗衣篮里拿了他邻居的脏衣服穿上，然后等待着。所以在摆脱手铐后，我拿了他的衣服穿上。我躺在被子底下，穿戴整齐，口袋里揣着一把刀，等着离开。但这里有一位对我一直很好的老太太。她走过来对我说，吉米，我讨厌看到像你这么好的年轻人被关在这里。
Then he slipped out of them when the guard left. He took his neighbor's dirty clothes out of the hamper, put them on, and waited. So after I got out of the handcuffs, I got his clothes and put them on. I was laying underneath the covers, fully dressed, a knife in my pocket waiting to leave. But they had this older lady that was always real nice to me. And she came by and told me, says, Jimmy, I hate to see a nice young man like you locked up like this.
这太不合情理了。我说，嗯，你知道的，妈妈，我有一种最奇怪的感觉，我不会被关那么久了。她一离开去别的病房，我就走了。吉米在逃亡中度过了一年半的时间。他从一个城市搬到另一个城市，借宿在朋友家，保持低调。当他回到洛杉矶时，他和一个几年前交往过的女人住在一起。他没有意识到联邦探员已经先一步找到了她。我去了她家，他们有联邦特工在屋里，屋外，
And it's just not right. I said, well, you know, Mom, I got the funniest feeling and I'm not going to be locked up all that longer. As soon as she left to go to the other ward, I was gone. Jimmy spent the next year and a half on the lamb. He moved from city to city, couch surfing, laying low. When he got back to L.A., he moved in with a woman he dated years earlier. He didn't realize the feds had gotten to her first. I went by her house, and they had feds in the house, outside the house,
树上以及其他地方，我想。因为他们到处都是。吉米于 1982 年回到安哥拉。他回去的第一天，就碰到了监狱长。他说，呀，呀，呀，吉米·科克斯又回到我们身边了。我说，对啊，怎么回事，老兄？他说，你什么意思怎么回事？我说，你们不是应该保护我的吗
up in trees and everything else, I reckon. Because they was everywhere. Jimmy returned to Angola in 1982. His first day back, he ran into the warden. And he said, well, well, well, we got Jimmy Cox back with us. And I said, yeah, what happened, man? He said, what do you mean, what happened? I said, you guys are supposed to be protecting me
结果有两个人进来把我从那个见鬼的医院里绑架了，老兄。然后他开始笑，你知道吗？他说，好吧，我告诉你，我要把你送到一个你不用担心别人绑架你的地方。他把我直接送到了 J 营（Camp Jay）。J 营是监狱的单人禁闭翼，相当于安哥拉的超级最高安全监狱。两年后他才被释放回到监狱的普通犯人群体中。然而，不到一个月后，吉米发现自己又回到了新奥尔良慈善医院，
and two people come in and kidnap me out that goddamn hospital, man. And he started laughing, you know? And he said, well, I'll tell you what, I'm going to send you someplace where you ain't got to worry about nobody kidnapping you. And he sent me straight to Camp Jay. Camp Jay was the prison's solitary wing, Angola's equivalent of a supermax. It was two years before he was released back into the prison's general population. And yet, less than a month later, Jimmy found himself back at Charity Hospital in New Orleans,
眼睛又受了伤。正如他所说，当安哥拉的医疗人员换届时，他自己把眼睛戳伤了。他们知道，但我的意思是，他们并不清楚以前发生的事情的具体内幕，你知道的。但这一次，慈善医院的工作人员更加警惕了。以前他们只是每两三个小时让警卫来看看你，对吧？但自从我上次逃跑后，他们开始安排所谓的“陪护”。这意味着他们会让一个警卫坐在你的病床旁。吉米再次将一把刀走私进了医院。有一次，他告诉警卫他
with another eye injury. As he told it, he'd poked himself in the eye when Angola's medical staff changed over. They knew, but I mean they weren't in with the nuts and bolts of what had happened before. you know. But this time, the staff at Charity were more vigilant. Before they had guards just come every two or three hours and check on you, right? But since my last escape, they started putting what they call a sit-own with you. That means they have a guard sitting at the bed with you. Once again, Jimmy had smuggled a knife into the hospital. At one point, he told the guard he
需要洗个澡，警卫答应了。当他走下来准备解开我脚上的脚镣时，我把刀架在他喉咙上并告诉他，我不想伤害你，我只是想回家。我真的不想伤害这个老头，你知道的？他试图反抗，所以我最后大概捅了他 13 刀，我想他们是这么说的。救了我一命、没让我杀死他的原因是，我朝他胸口刺了一下，然后我准备补上致命一击，但他把双手都举起来挡在了我击中的地方，刀穿透了他的双手，刀刃不够长，无法刺入任何要害器官，这在当时是
needed a shower and the guard obliged. And when he went down to take my shackles off my feet, and I put the knife to a stroke and told him, I don't want to hurt you, I just want to go home. I really didn't want to hurt the old man, you know? He tried to fight, so I wound up stabbing him about 13 times, I think they said. What saved me from killing him, I hit him one time in the chest and I come in for the kill shot, but he had stuck both hands up where I hit him at, and the knife went through both hands, and it didn't have enough blade to penetrate any vital organ, which was for the first.
对我很幸运，否则我现在就是个死人了。他们会把我处决的。这一次，吉米从窗户跳到太平梯上，然后从侧门离开了医院。不到一个月后，他说，他在纽约找到了临时工作。84 年 8 月，我在皇后区的卑尔根狩猎钓鱼俱乐部（Bergen Hunting and Fishing Club）坐着，和一个臭名昭H的人喝着啤酒。你能说出那个声名狼藉的人是谁吗？戈蒂。那是约翰·戈蒂（John Gotti），
fortunate for me because I'd have been a dead cracker right now. They'd have executed me. This time, Jimmy jumped out a window onto the fire escape, then exited the hospital through a side entrance. Less than a month later, he said, he found temporary employment in New York. In August of 84, I was sitting in the Bergen hunting fish club in Queens and enjoying a beer with a very infamous person. Can you say who that infamous person was? Goddy. That's Gotti, as in John Gotti. head of New York's notorious Gambino Crime Family.
纽约臭名昭著的甘比诺犯罪家族的头目。吉米说他在约翰·戈蒂的手下工作了几个月，然后搬到了肯塔基州。在洛杉矶被抓获后，他觉得自己可以试着在一个小镇上隐姓埋名。但吉米不是那种整天闷在家里的人。是的，我开着一辆挂着新泽西州车牌的全新埃尔多拉多（El Dorado）。然后我带着一个火辣的小妞。她穿着皮大衣之类的东西。
Jimmy said he worked for John Gotti's crew for a few months before relocating to Kentucky. After getting captured in L.A., he figured he'd try to hide out in a small town. But Jimmy wasn't the type to stay cooped up in his house all day. Yeah, I'm driving a brand new El Dorado with New Jersey license place on it. And then I had this little hot chick. She's wearing fur coats and shit.
我这是自找的。据吉米说，肯塔基州调查局的一个爱管闲事的特工怀疑他抢劫了一家当地银行，但他坚称自己没有这么做。不管怎样，有一天他回到家，发现自己再次被包围了。他们有州警察、联邦调查局以及所有其他白痴。当我看到他们时，我拔腿就跑。那家伙从阳台上跳下来，落在我脖子上，把一把小迷你 14 步枪塞进我嘴里。他说，现在跑啊，现在跑啊。
I was asking for it. According to Jimmy, a nosy agent from the Kentucky Bureau of Investigation suspected him of robbing a local bank, which he claims he didn't do. Either way, he came home one day to find himself surrounded again. They had the state police, the FBI, and all them other idiots. When I seen him, I took off running. The dude jumped off a balcony and landed on my neck and stuck a little one of them little mini-14s in my mouth. He said, run now, run now.
我说，把枪从我嘴里拿开，贱人，然后我就跑。不过他并没有把枪从我嘴里拿出来。当时，吉米随身带着一张标明他是詹姆斯·阿洛伊斯·亚当斯三世（James Aloysius Adams III）的身份证。警察以为他只是个当地黑帮。他们没有意识到他们抓到的是一个在安哥拉服无期徒刑的两次越狱犯。经过初审后，他们犯了一个错误，把吉米带出法院时没有戴手铐或脚镣。他一拳打在狱警的脸上，然后跑了。但在肯塔基州的一个小镇上，他仅仅几个小时就被抓获了。
I said, we'll get the gun on my mouth, bitch, and I'll run. He didn't take it out my mouth, though. At the time, Jimmy was carrying an ID that identified him as James Aloysius Adams III. The cops assumed he was just a local gangster. They didn't realize they had a two-time escapee serving a life sentence at Angola. After a preliminary hearing, they made the mistake of taking Jimmy out of the courthouse without handcuffs or shackles. He punched the jailer in the face and ran off. But in small town, Kentucky, he was captured after just a few hours.
你知道，那些乡村小镇，老兄，他们全都盯着我呢。就像苍蝇逐血一样。吉米因企图越狱在肯塔基州立监狱被判处七年监禁。幸运的是，这与安哥拉完全不同。我第一次去安哥拉时，我是个文盲。我可以给你写张便条，把所有的钱都放进这个包里。你知道我的意思吗？但我写不出一封正式的信。
You know, them country towns, man, they was all on me. like white on rights. Jimmy got seven years at the Kentucky State Penitentiary for the escape attempt. Luckily, it was nothing like Angola. When I went to Angola the first time, I was functionally illiterate. I could write you a note, put all the money in this bag. You know what I mean? But I couldn't write a formal letter.
当我在肯塔基州的那个监狱时，他们非常支持教育。我最后获得了大学学位、律师助理学位，并且我正在攻读成瘾咨询学位。吉米遇到了一位监狱心理学家，她帮助他处理了他在童年时期经历的创伤，特别是大波利的谋杀案。她是我从 11 岁起第一个向其讲述那个故事的人。她引导我走出了阴影。她告诉我，你不能根据一桩事件来衡量你的整个人生。我们进行了很多次对话，还有很多，你知道的，这不是一朝一夕就能发生的事情，但这对我是个重大突破。
While I was in that prison in Kentucky, they were real pro-education. I wound up getting a college degree, a paralegal degree, and I was working on addiction counseling degree. Jimmy met a prison psychologist who helped him process the trauma he'd experienced as a kid, specifically Big Polly's murder. She was the very first person since I was 11 years old that I told that story to. She worked me through it. She told me, says, you can't gauge your whole life based on one incident. We had a lot of conversations and a lot of, you know, it wasn't something that happened overnight, but it was a major breakthrough for me.
这就像卸下了沉重的包袱。服刑几年后，他的一个挚友因他和吉米一起吸食的海洛因过量而死亡。吉米说，他断断续续吸食海洛因已经 20 多年了，但他在那之后不久就戒了。我只是向上帝请求了一件简单的事。我说，上帝，我不知道怎么祈祷，但我只是请求你让我
It was like kind of shedding a whole lot of weight. A few years into his sentence, a close friend overdosed on heroin that he and Jimmy were using together. Jimmy had been using heroin off and on for over 20 years, he says, but he quit soon after. I just asked God a simple thing. I said, God, I don't know how to pray, but I'm just asking you to just relieve you. me of this addiction. I started shooting heroin in 66, Jed. That was a long run, you know. I haven't touched narcotics. I have a Louisiana medical marijuana card, but I haven't touched any real narcotics since then. Jimmy changed while incarcerated in Kentucky. He got an education.
摆脱这个瘾。我在 66 年开始注射海洛因，杰德。那是一段很长的瘾头，你知道的。我再也没有碰过麻醉品。我有一张路易斯安那州的医用大麻卡，但自那以后我没有碰过任何真正的麻醉品。吉米在肯塔基州服刑期间改变了。他接受了教育。
He got clean. He found a purpose in addiction counseling. But in 1993, his sentence in Kentucky came to an end. Jimmy was shipped back to Angola, back to the bloodiest prison in America, where he was due to spend the remainder of his natural life. When Jimmy returned to Angola in 1993, after 11 years away, he found it relatively unchanged. He, on the other hand, felt like a different person. The change surprised many of his old pals. I got back to Angola. I kind of didn't get high anymore. A lot of guys were disappointed when I come back, because when they They seen me, they said, oh man, good. We had some good dope now.
他戒了毒。他在戒毒咨询中找到了人生目标。但在 1993 年，他在肯塔基州的刑期结束了。吉米被运回了安哥拉，回到了那个美国最血腥的监狱，他将在那里度过余生。当吉米在 1993 年离开 11 年后重返安哥拉时，他发现这里几乎没有变化。另一方面，他觉得自己像个不同的人。这种转变让他的许多老朋友感到惊讶。我回到安哥拉。我基本上不再吸毒了。当我回来时，许多家伙都很失望，因为当他们
I said, nah, I don't mess around no more, buddy. And people couldn't believe it because my life had taken on a whole different lane, so to speak. Not long after his return, director Stephen Soderberg shot a scene from his film out of sight inside Angola. The film follows the story of a charming bank robber, played by George Clooney, who escapes from prison and kidnaps a U.S. Marshall, played by Jennifer Lopez. In the scene, George Clooney is planning his escape with other inmates in the Chow Hall. According to Jimmy, Soderberg wanted real-life Angola inmates to appear in the scene.
看到我时，他们说，哦，天哪，太好了。我们现在有优质的毒品了。我说，不，我再也不瞎混了，老兄。人们简直不敢相信，因为我的生活已经走上了完全不同的轨道，可以这么说。就在他回去后不久，导演史蒂文·索德伯格（Stephen Soderberg）在他的电影《战略高手》（Out of Sight）中，在安哥拉内部拍摄了一个场景。该片讲述了一个迷人的银行劫匪（由乔治·克鲁尼饰演）越狱并绑架了一名美国法警（由詹妮弗·洛佩兹饰演）的故事。在那个场景中，乔治·克鲁尼正与其他囚犯在食堂计划越狱。据吉米说，索德伯格希望现实生活中的安哥拉囚犯出现在这个场景中。
Angola's warden recommended Jimmy, maybe thinking his multiple escapes would bring some realism to it. Warden Van Oggard picked me and told me, said, Jimmy, we need you to go over there and sit at that table where George Clooney and them other two actors are going to be sitting because we don't want to put one these idiots over there that would embarrass us. So I said, okay, boss, I went over there. And I didn't even know who Clooney was. I remember asking Van Oh, I said, who the hell is this guy? He said, he played Batman, you know, like I go to the movies, you know? So the director told me to say, just talk about whatever you would talk about while you're at Chow. As he described it, Jimmy brought a little too much realism to the scene.
安哥拉的前监狱长推荐了吉米，可能是认为他多次越狱会给影片带来一些真实感。监狱长范·奥加德（Van Oggard）选中了我，并告诉我，吉米，我们需要你去那边坐在乔治·克鲁尼和其他两个演员要坐的桌子旁，因为我们不想把其中一个会让我们难堪的白痴安排在那儿。所以我说，好的，老板，我过去了。我甚至不知道克鲁尼是谁。我记得我问范·奥，我说，这家伙到底是谁？他说，他演过蝙蝠侠，你知道的，就像我看电影一样，你知道吗？所以导演告诉我说，就聊你在食堂时会聊的任何事情。正如他所描述的那样，吉米给这个场景带来了一点过于真实的色彩。
He suggested some graphic things they could do to the warden before running off. The scene didn't make the final cut. And then afterwards, they might have had a little problem from the legal department or whatever, you know? Because Clooney told me, said, man, that was good. And what did you say to Clooney? I tell him, I'm always good. Despite his supporting role in a George Clooney movie, Jimmy was not happy to be back.
他建议在逃跑之前对监狱长做一些大尺度的恶劣事情。这个场景没有进入最终的剪辑版本。然后在那之后，他们可能从法律部门或其他什么地方遇到了一点小麻烦，你知道的？因为克鲁尼对我说，老兄，那演得真好。你对克鲁尼说了什么？我告诉他，我一直都演得很好。尽管他在乔治·克鲁尼的电影中扮演了配角，但吉米对回来并不高兴。
But rather than plot a third escape attempt, he put his new paralegal degree to work. He began researching ways of getting his murder conviction overturned. He filed an appeal for post-conviction relief, noting that before his murder trial in the mid-70s, he'd been denied a competency hearing, despite the fact that he was addicted to hate. heroin and PCP.
不过，他没有策划第三次越狱，而是把他的新律师助理学位派上了用场。他开始研究推翻谋杀定罪的方法。他提交了一份审判后救济的上诉，指出在 70 年代中期他的谋杀案审判之前，尽管事实是他对海洛因和 PCP 上瘾，但他被剥夺了听取其行为能力听证会的权利。
The New Orleans DA was overwhelmed with caseloads at the time. Rather than retry Jimmy's murder case, the DA allowed him to plead guilty to attempted robbery instead. The charge carried a 40-year sentence instead of life. As part of the deal, Jimmy's murder convictions were wiped from his record. He'd always assumed he would die at Angola. Now he found himself with less than 10 years left to serve. Jimmy stayed at Angola until 1998, when for good behavior, he was transgender. transferred to a number of medium security prisons,
当时新奥尔良地区检察官的工作量不堪重负。为了不重新审理吉米的谋杀案，地区检察官允许他改判为企图抢劫罪。该指控判处 40 年监禁，而不是终身监禁。作为协议的一部分，吉米谋杀罪的定罪被从他的记录中抹去了。他一直以为自己会死在安哥拉。现在他发现自己只剩下不到 10 年的刑期了。吉米在安哥拉呆到 1998 年，由于表现良好，他被转运了。转到了几所中等安全级别的监狱，
including Washington Correctional Institute, or WC.I. In the town of Bogalusa. At WC.I, Jimmy applied to become a trustee, the inmates who get special privileges, like getting to leave the prison grounds under supervision. Based on his two prior escape attempts, his request kept getting denied. So Jimmy finally appealed to the warden himself.
包括博加卢萨（Bogalusa）镇的华盛顿惩教所（Washington Correctional Institute，简称 W.C.I.）。在 W.C.I，吉米申请成为一名受信任囚犯（trustee），即那些获得特殊特权（如在监督下离开监狱 grounds）的囚犯。根据他之前两次越狱的尝试，他的请求一直被拒绝。所以吉米最终直接向监狱长本人上诉。
I went and caught the warden named Jim Miller. I told him, I said, man, look, I'm trying to make trustee. I said, I go home in a couple years. I just want to be able to get a little scene of what's happening out there, so I ain't going out in a complete haze. And I said, I haven't had a write-up in 10 years. I said, I don't even own a knife. If I wanted to escape, I escaped from Mangola twice.
我去找了一位名叫吉姆·米勒（Jim Miller）的监狱长。我告诉他，我说，老兄，听着，我正努力争取成为受信任囚犯。我说，我再过几年就出狱了。我只是想能够对外面发生的事情有一个小小的了解，这样我出去时就不会完全一无所知了。我说，我已经 10 年没有违纪记录了。我说我甚至连一把刀都没有。如果我想逃跑，我从安哥拉逃过两次。
This would be like opening up a tuna fish can here. And he said, I tell you what, Jimmy, you write me a note and tell me, says, check out my file per hour conversation this morning. I did that. Next week, I was on reclass and made trustee. A few years later, Jimmy was in his cell when he and other inmates got word of a massive storm brewing in the Gulf of Mexico. Hurricane Katrina made landfall the next day. WCI was hit hard. The storm knocked down the prison's 10-foot-high perimeter fence.
这就像在这里打开一个金枪鱼罐头一样容易。他说，我告诉你，吉米，你给我写张便条，告诉我说，根据我们今早的谈话检查一下我的档案。我照做了。第二周，我在重新分类后就成为了受信任囚犯。几年后，吉米正在牢房里，他和别的囚犯得知墨西哥湾正在酝酿一场特大风暴。飓风卡特里娜（Hurricane Katrina）于次日登陆。W.C.I. 遭受了重创。风暴刮倒了监狱 10 英尺高的周界围栏。
H-VAC systems were blown off the roofs. Fallen trees made the road into the prison impassable. If there was ever a time to escape from prison, this was it. Instead, Jimmy and a dozen other trustees braved the wind and rain to weld the HVAC system back into place. As the storm subsided, they cleared the main roads in the parish with chainsaws. They drove forklifts and distributed food and water to people whose homes had been destroyed. Every day, I would go out to the FEMA area, and I'll be honest with you. Man, it brought joy to my old heart to see the happiness and thankfulness of people.
空调系统被从屋顶上吹落。倒下的树木使通往监狱的道路无法通行。如果说有什么时候适合越狱，那就是现在。相反，吉米和其他十几名受信任囚犯冒着风雨，用电焊将空调系统焊回原位。随着风暴消退，他们用链锯清理了教区的主干道。他们开着叉车向家园被毁的人们分发食物和水。每天，我都会去联邦紧急事务管理局（FEMA）的区域，老实说。老兄，看到人们的快乐和感激之情，给我的老心带来了一阵喜悦。
They didn't see us as prisoners. They saw us as people that was right there trying to help them. The story of prison inmates providing hurricane relief made national news. Reporters gravitated to Jimmy. Well, the Wall Street Journal and a whole bunch of other news outlets interviewed me. And the Wall Street Journal had my picture on the front page of his newspaper. After we spoke, I looked up the Wall Street Journal article. Sure enough, there was Jimmy on the front page beneath the headline, Warden's Chainsaw Gang.
他们没有把我们看作囚犯。他们把我们看作是就在那里试图帮助他们的人。囚犯提供飓风救援的故事成了全国新闻。记者们纷纷被吉米吸引。嗯，《华尔街日报》和其他一大堆新闻媒体采访了我。《华尔街日报》把我的照片登在了报纸的头版。我们交谈后，我查阅了《华尔街日报》的那篇文章。果然，吉米登上了头版，标题是《监狱长的链锯帮》（Warden's Chainsaw Gang）。
A few days later, I called him to ask about the article. The RV park he was staying at didn't have Wi-Fi, so I taped the call on my phone. How you doing, man? Hey, Jimmy. How's the camp? Oh, it's nice. I love it up here, man.
几天后，我打电话向他询问这篇文章的事。他所在的房车公园没有无线网络，所以我在手机上录下了这次通话。你好啊，老兄。嘿，吉米。营地怎么样？哦，很好。我很喜欢这里，老兄。
It had been years since he'd seen the Wall Street Journal article, so I read him an excerpt from it. As you said in the article is a beautiful statement. Here, I'll read. I have it right here. This is your quote. I've been a thug since 1966, and this feels good, said Mr. Cox,
他已经好几年没看过《华尔街日报》的那篇文章了，所以我读了一段摘录给他听。正如你在文章中所说的那是一个美丽的陈述。来，我读一下。我这里就有。这是你的原话。我自 1966 年以来一直是个暴徒，这感觉真好，科克斯先生说，
a brawny tattooed 53-year-old. Quote, when people come up and you look in their faces and see all the sadness and then they thank you, like you're the only one giving this stuff to them. Talk to me about that. Well, it was basically just being out in society and being able to help. You know, for so many years, I was just locked away, shunned away. Thinking about this shit even brings tears to mine. Yeah, I can imagine. You know, it felt good to be able to help.
一个身材魁梧、满身刺青的 53 岁男子。引用原话：当人们走过来，你看着他们的脸，看到所有的悲伤，然后他们感谢你，就像你是唯一一个把这些东西施舍给他们的人。跟我聊聊这个。嗯，这基本上就是回归社会并能够提供帮助。你知道的，多少年里，我只是被锁起来，被抛弃。一想到这些狗屁事甚至让我眼眶湿润。是的，我能想象。你知道的，能够提供帮助感觉很好。
You know, you hurt people all your life. And then all of a sudden, you get an opportunity to help. And I followed that tradition still. I get stuck out and messed over, helping people, but I'm not giving up. I feel like I'm on a mission in a sense, you know, man, to show people that, hey, you know, no matter how screwed up you were, you can be better. You can come out here no matter how many years you do in prison as succeed. And that's what Jimmy did. When he was released from prison in 2006, a friend helped him find work doing offshore construction on oil rigs in the Gulf of Mexico.
你知道，你一辈子都在伤害别人。然后突然之间，你得到了一个帮助别人的机会。我至今仍然遵循着那个传统。我有时会因为帮助别人而吃亏受罪，但我并没有放弃。我觉得我在某种意义上肩负着使命，你知道的，老兄，向人们展示，嘿，你知道的，不管你以前多么混账，你都可以变得更好。无论你在监狱里服刑多少年，你都可以走出来并取得成功。吉米就是这么做的。2006 年出狱后，一位朋友帮他在墨西哥湾的石油钻井平台上找到了一份海上建设的工作。
He got his first legal paycheck at 54 years old. A framed copy of the pay stub hangs on his living room wall. Jimmy went on to become a safety consultant for the offshore industry. In his spare time, he created a prison reentry program called Phoenix Ministries, It helped former Angola inmates transition back into society. Inside the prison, word got around of Jimmy's success on the outside. Angola's former warden, Darrell Van Noy, talked about Jimmy's transformation at a conference put on by the American Correctional Association.
他在 54 岁时领到了人生第一张合法工资支票。一张裱起来的工资单复印件挂在他客厅的墙上。吉米后来成为海上工业的安全顾问。在闲暇之余，他创立了一个名为“凤凰事工”（Phoenix Ministries）的监狱重返社会项目。它帮助前安哥拉囚犯重新融入社会。在监狱内部，关于吉米在外面的成功的故事广为流传。安哥拉前监狱长达勒·范·诺伊（Darrell Van Noy）在美国惩教协会（American Correctional Association）举办的一个会议上谈到了吉米的转变。
So, after speaking with Jimmy, I reached out to Darrell. It turned out the two of them had known each other for almost 50 years. Darrell was a young prison guard in Angola when Jimmy first showed up in the mid-70s. When Jimmy got there, he continued. He had lived at criminal life. When he was young, he was a real deal. He was a real gangster, you know. He was a real outlaw.
所以在和吉米交谈后，我联系了达雷尔。原来他们两人认识快50年了。20世纪70年代中期吉米刚进安哥拉监狱时，达雷尔是一名年轻的狱警。吉米到那儿后，依然我行我素，过着罪犯的生活。他年轻时是个狠角色，真的是个黑帮分子，你知道的，是个真正的法外之徒。
But Van Nuoy had watched Jimmy rehabilitate himself. When he got out, the two of them stayed in touch, and they eventually became friends. He's my friend, yeah, I consider him a friend. After he discharged, you know, he never returned to prison, never violated again, and he put his life for crying behind him. I would welcome him as my neighbor. Yeah, you would, huh?
但范努伊一直看着吉米改过自新。他出狱后，两人保持着联系，最终成为了朋友。“他是我的朋友，是的，我把他当朋友，”他出狱后你知道的，再也没有回过监狱，再也没有违过法，把哭泣的生活抛在了脑后。“我会欢迎他做我的邻居。”“是吗，你会的？”
If he moved in the next door, I'd be proud to have him for a night. Jimmy Cox retired in 2020. He lives with his fiancé and three dogs in Lafayette, Louisiana. But when I spoke to him last, he was unwinding in a state park not far away. I was telling someone the other day that I've come full circle. I got out of prison right there, and now I'm within 20 miles at a prison, and I'm enjoying life laying up in a state park and a $40,000 camper. Got a beautiful lady.
“如果他搬到隔壁，有他这样一个邻居我会很骄傲。”吉米·考克斯于2020年退休。他和未婚夫以及三只狗住在路易斯安那州拉斐特。但当我最后一次和他交谈时，他正在不远处的一个州立公园里放松。“我前几天跟别人说我终于圆满了。我就是在那儿出狱的，现在我在离监狱20英里以内的地方，我正躺在价值4万美元的露营车里，在州立公园里享受生活。还有一个漂亮的女士。”
I'm in his full circle, you know, Jed? If you have information, story tips, or feedback you'd like to share with the Gone South team, please email us at Gone South Podcast at gmail.com. That's Gone South Podcast at gmail.com. Gone South is an Odyssey original podcast. It's created, written, and narrated by me, Jedd Lepinski. Our executive producers are Jenna Weiss-Burman, Maddie Sprung-Kaiser,
“我这叫功德圆满，对吧，杰德？”如果您有信息、故事线索或反馈想与《南方已逝》团队分享，请发电子邮件至 Gone South Podcast at gmail.com。即 Gone South Podcast at gmail.com。《南方已逝》是 Odyssey 的原创播客。由我，杰德·莱平斯基创作、撰写并担任旁白。我们的执行制片人是珍娜·韦斯-伯曼、马迪·斯普伦格-凯瑟，
Tom Lopensky, Lloyd Lockeridge, and me. Our story editors are Maddie Sprung-Kaiser and Tom Lipinski. Gone South is edited, mixed, and mastered by Chris Basil and Andy Jaskowitz. Production support from Ian Mont and Sean Cherry. Special thanks to J.D. Crowley, Leah Reese Dennis, Mora Curran, Josephina Francis, Kurt Courtney, and Hillary Schuff. If you want to hear more of Gone South, Please take a few seconds to rate and review the show.
汤姆·洛彭斯基、劳埃德·洛克里奇还有我。我们的故事编辑是马迪·斯普伦格-凯瑟和汤姆·利平斯基。《南方已逝》由克里斯·巴西尔和安迪·贾斯科维茨负责剪辑、混音和母带制作。制作支持来自伊恩·蒙特和肖恩·切里。特别感谢 J.D. 克劳利、莉亚·里斯·丹尼斯、莫拉·柯兰、约瑟芬娜·弗朗西斯、库尔特·考特尼和希拉里·舒夫。如果您想收听更多《南方已逝》的内容，请花几秒钟为节目评分并撰写评论。
It really helps. For full episodes, follow Gone South, an Odyssey original podcast available now on the free Odyssey app and wherever you get your podcasts. We hope you guys have a great week, and we'll see you next week. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
这真的很有帮助。要收听完整单集，请关注《南方已逝》，这是 Odyssey 的原创播客，现已在免费的 Odyssey 应用程序以及您获取播客的任何地方上线。希望大家度过美好的一周，我们下周见。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。